[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with economist
carol malone and the independence chief
political commentator
john rental they'll be with us right
through until
midnight let's hope they're still
smiling by then
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now tech giants like
google netflix
and facebook have said that staff will
need to be fully vaccinated before
returning to the office
that's according to the metro an
approach which
foreign secretary dominic raab appeared
to welcome earlier today
says the daily mail the telegraph has
seen data which suggests one in four
patients listed
as covert admissions are actually being
treated for other
conditions the mirror reports the uk's
vaccine rollout has saved around
60 000 lives and prevented 22 million
positive cases
the express reports the eu is about to
start a travel war
by restricting the movement of fully
vaccinated travelers from the uk
in response to post-brexit trade
discussions
which the times describes as a
diplomatic backlash
for the uk over excessive quarantine for
french travellers
an all-party committee of mps has found
the police and the government have done
little to get rid of radical injustice
within the force that's in the guardian
the financial times reports that the
conservative party has received
18 million pounds in donations from the
property sector
since boris johnson became prime
minister accounting for a quarter
of all gifts received the sun reports on
anger from fans of tv personality katie
price
who were allegedly conned out of
thousands of pounds by someone she
promoted
on her social media account
and we are joined as i was saying
tonight by carol malone
and john rental welcome to
you both let's kick off with the mirror
um and their headline there jabs save 60
000 lives and this is uh the positive
information that we've been receiving
over
several weeks actually that the
vaccinations are are doing their job
carol
yeah i mean it sounds great it sounds
really good and we're told that i think
it's
52 000 um hospital admissions have been
averted as well
but it's interesting because i just was
reading some analysis on this figure
today not to put a damper on this but
the analysis said that the figure was a
bit of an exaggeration because
the model that was used as what would
happen in a world was no vaccination and
no lockdown
and the model is behind the figure
looked at the number of infections we've
seen since the start of the year
and then asked how many of those
infected people would have died
if the death rates from 2020 still
applied so we don't actually
know if this figure is true it sounds
great and i hope it's i hope it's true
um we certainly know that the infections
are dropping now
in all age groups we know that i mean
there was one because
i had dr david matthew today neurologist
he said that barring something
spectacular happening in the next couple
of months he said the
pandemics all but over um i don't know
if we can quite believe that
yet um and professor johnson van tam our
deputy chief medical officer
has said that is not the case but
certainly hospital admissions
um they're not going down they've gone
up a bit but they're not
terrible um and and the deaths have kind
of
got their they're kind of stinkish so
you know
it's not looking too terrible uh
john do you think that's with reckless
talk to to say that the pandemics are
all but over i mean
this look to be positive but but that's
quite extreme to say that pandemic we're
out of it
well i know i do think it's important to
be clear that
uh the worst over
and i think it's worth uh we're
celebrating that i mean obviously you
can understand why
jonathan vantam and uh leading
politicians don't want to be
too uh triumphalist in public because
uh things may still be difficult over
the
over the winter uh but i think it is
essentially
uh past us and i well i certainly hope
so
and it seems to be that what the
scientists are saying is that
we're close to it to a form of of herd
immunity although that's probably a
banned term now but but that seems to be
that the stage to which we we have now
arrived
carol well the marker for that sits
at somewhere around 93 percent and if
we're close to that
i mean that's fantastic it's dipping in
every age group in the in the young and
the middle age and the elderly
and interestingly in the 20s it's
dipping the fastest
so so this is all contributing to herd
immunity and then
you know remember the scientists told us
not too long ago that we'll be having a
hundred thousand infections a day by now
possibly two hundred thousand so this is
great news
let's move on to the mail uh and they're
looking at uh the link between um
employment and actually being double
jabbed
many people fearful that this will be
the future and we'll have a two-tier
society john yeah this is
very controversial um and it's the same
same story that uh
that is in the metro that you read out
earlier which actually names
some of the companies involved saying
google in the uk
is going to require evidence of double
vaccination
for people uh before they before they're
allowed back into the office
that that is going to be controversial
i'm not sure i want to have
uh i want to have a passport on my
on my phone i'm quite happy with my
little cardboard
thingy which i keep in my uh in my past
in my actual passport which is
uh um which is which is all i want to do
i don't i don't want
a uh a state identity card on my
smartphone thank you carol what say you
i have to say you know i'm a little bit
more
relaxed about that i get why companies
are demanding that their staff be
vaccinated companies have been
you know almost out of business for the
last 16 months
times have been tough and you know
they've struggled to stay afloat and
some of them haven't
stayed afloat so you can see why when
staff come back to work they want to
make sure
that they're working in safe conditions
and i would have thought the staff going
into the office every day or what
wherever their job is
you would have thought they would have
wanted to be safe too you know this
stuff about the government are talking
about where it's like
it's a it's a a passport by
stealth where you you know it's put on
your uh nhs app
i mean i'm not too worried about that as
long as these things are all
temporary as long as they're just for a
period
and the fact of the matter is i don't
want to be mixing with
loads of people who haven't been jabbed
it is their right not to be jabbed but
it's my right
not to want to be infected by them john
do you think that i mean cows raised
the point that she's happy if these
measures are temporary isn't that the
issue that that many people are worried
that it's by stealth and it's it's a
creeping nature of
of government imposing on people and
this
could just be the start of things to
come yeah i mean i just don't
don't think it's necessary i mean if it
is if it is needed temporarily
then it's probably not needed at all
because uh if as carol says we're
approaching
herd immunity and the rate of infections
is
declining uh then i just don't see i
i think this is a solution uh to a
problem which doesn't exist
uh or at least i hope hope that is going
to be the case uh
very soon and so i just don't think
there's a need for
uh compulsory requirements to to have
uh to have a vaccine passport
yeah there is a bit of a contradiction
john isn't ever you know now the
government
are backtracking on um saying you have
to be vaccinated for
you know hundreds of young people going
into a nightclub
um which i think is the very place you
should be vaccinated
and yet you know people are going to
have to be vaccinated to go to work
i'd far rather it seems up to me that
you're going to be vaccinated to go to
work but
you can still go to a club and you can
still go to an event and you can still
be face to face
in in a kind of petty dish atmosphere
with with hundreds and thousands of
people where you will very probably get
it yeah no it does seem that there needs
to be
some sort of uniformity in what's that
required let's have a quick look at the
daily
telegraph and this story pointing to the
fact that um hospital
covert cases that the numbers that we're
getting are misleading
and that patients were actually admitted
for other causes other than than covert
job
yeah no this is something that the
anti-lockdown has
been banging on about for some time um
it is obviously the case that there are
some people in hospital
who are being treated for other things
who have either caught
uh coronavirus in hospital or have
tested positive since
since they arrived but i mean this is
this is just making us
a simple arithmetical mistake because
the point is the numbers of people in
in hospital uh with coronavirus go up
and down
and most of them are there because of
coronavirus
uh and so although the number may not be
uh
accurate it's the trend that matters and
the trend uh
is is looking quite hopeful at the
moment it's looking as if it's going as
if it's leveling off and uh maybe
heading downward soon
very quickly carol is this then nothing
to worry about no i kind of disagree
because one in four patients
are in hospital and they weren't
admitted with covet and i think what it
means is i think that
the bigger point is that restrictions on
our freedoms
have been based on inflated statistics
so what the government did two or three
four weeks ago
the fact that they're not lifting the
restrictions now until august
that's that's based on floor statistics
of
fight there with this survey they did
this thing a 5021 clusters hospitalized
by
coverage 1166 were being
in hospital being treated for other
reasons and so the government is making
policy
on onslaught flawed data
carol and john stay right where you are
we are going to take a break
coming up the x factor paxt but will we
miss
the show many considered exploitative
we'll discuss that next who stay with us
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me tonight
carol malone and john rental um
just for this short section let's start
with uh simone barles and this is uh the
metro
how they've covered uh the fact that the
gymnast has withdrawn
from the olympics um
some people not very sympathetic carol
i don't blame them for not being
sympathetic i mean yeah
a lot of the hollywood crowd of are
saying how brave and wonderful and
fantastic she is
and i mean there's nothing great or
fantastic about quitting
if she thinks she might do herself
physical
physical harm i you know not be able to
perform
she was wrong about no i know she's not
worried about physical harm but
the mental anguish that she's going
through affects her physical performance
and gymnastics
means that she could seriously harm
herself if she's not in the right frame
of mind
stop the olympics so don't go to the
olympics then if you have mental issues
don't put yourself in a team to
represent your country at the olympics
and mental issues don't happen overnight
so there should be definitely
oh dear what's up we've lost you there a
bit carol but let's bring let's bring
john in on
that uh yeah i think this
i think carol's been much too harsh um i
think this is a huge step forward for
um you know to allow athletes or anybody
in in public life
to say when uh when things are too much
for them and to explain that uh
you know they don't they don't want to
carry on doing something i think that's
that's entirely healthy and a good thing
and we ought to learn and i hope the
tennis authorities
uh learn from that because there was
that uh there was that tennis player who
didn't want to do the post match
no he has that yeah um and i think
uh i think we just should be a bit a bit
more uh understanding of
uh of of the pressures these people are
under and
uh i think it's entirely a good thing
carol though can i ask you one question
do you seriously think she would
do you seriously think she would go all
the way to tokyo
and not perform if she wasn't under some
serious pressure
do you seriously think that her mental
issues occurred
just as she got to token i don't know
i've no idea because i don't believe
that they did
well i don't believe that what i'm
saying is i think if she has mental
issues that were probably
there but before what the quote she said
which really surprised me she said
i feel like i'm not having much fun
you're not at the olympics to have fun
you're at the olympics it's the ultimate
test of an athlete
you're there to represent your country
and to support your team
and she pulled out of her team and
andrew lost
and russia won the medal would you would
have she been in it
has there been any point in in your life
where you felt that that you
you couldn't cope and you had to to
withdraw from from whatever it was
well that's what's happened to her why
are you so unsympathetic i
give it to you what do you want me just
to to agree with what everyone else is
no i'm just i'm just
wondering why you're so unsympathetic as
john said it's not it's not
my opinion i'm just wondering where
where that sort of comes from
well it seems like it is frankly julian
it seems like it is your opinion
i'm not being unsympathetic i'm telling
you what i think
and i think an athlete who goes to tokyo
to to partake in the games
if she if before she went to the games
she wasn't
feeling well enough to be there she
shouldn't have gone there and
and i bet you asked a lot of teammates
and a lot of the other athletes they
will say they're all under the same
pressure
that she is it's a higher pressure it's
a high-pressure business
john no i don't i mean i just don't
agree i mean i think anybody can
can suffer from moments of stage fright
or
sudden uh you know it can just come
across
come on you suddenly uh and i think if
you
are just open about it and honest about
it and say what's happening and
that you you can't carry on then i think
that's
that's better and more healthy than
people uh
feeling that they have to maintain some
kind of public front
guys do you guys know anything about
this girl have you ever listened to her
in the past the way she talks her levels
of confidence
she's one of the most confident athletes
i've ever well
to the public we're going to have to
leave it there because we've run out of
time carol